[Music]
you are watching The Press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive in the next half hour
we'll see what's making the headlines
with journalist and author Rachel shabby
and acting Deputy political editor of
the mail on Sunday Claire Ellicott so
let us see what is on some of those
front pages for you now a retired
British Army Officer says the UK's Armed
Forces need a 3 billion pound yearly
boost in order to replenish the weapons
and tanks given to Ukraine and maintain
a fighting ability that's according to
the Sunday Express
the times goes with Iran International
TV having to stop broadcasting from its
London headquarters after the
independent broadcaster says that staff
have received threats from Tehran
the telegraph reports that Boris Johnson
is warning Rishi sunak that overhauling
Northern Ireland's post-brexit
Arrangements would be a great mistake
Mr Johnson's fight to keep the Northern
Ireland protocol is also on the front of
the Observer
the mail on Sunday claims prince Andrew
fears he'll lose his 30 million pound
Windsor home if his brother King Charles
slashes his annual Grant
the mirror leads with Katie Price
hitting out at the Metropolitan Police
as officers are accused of mocking her
disabled son in a WhatsApp group
and reminded that by scanning the QR
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us
and we are joined tonight by Rachel
shabby and Claire Ellicott welcome to
you both let's start with the Observer
and their front page story the headline
Johnson threatens sunax bid to end
deadlock over brexit the former prime
minister making an intervention Rachel
yes another intervention from former
prime minister Boris Johnson he's a bit
of a bad loser isn't he and it does seem
to be hanging around
um Rishi sunax Premiership like a bad
smell
um sunak has been engaged in
um talks over the Northern Ireland
protocol and they seem to be coming
along quite well I mean all of the sides
are saying pretty much the same thing
which in itself is a good sign and
they're saying that
there's still a long way to go but
things are looking good in reaching a
resolution over that
um Northern Ireland agreement
but Boris Johnson has turned up
to say well this is very bad because it
um potentially will ditch the
um legislation that he put in which
allows the UK government to rip up
brexit arrangements
um unilaterally now
obviously that in itself being that that
legislation to unilaterally rip up
agreements of the EU Is Not Great sunak
is saying saying we won't need it if we
reach this protocol we won't need it but
it's interesting that you know Johnson
is basically sniffing blood isn't he
he's seeing this opportunity he's seen
you know back bencher Rebels within
um the conservatives who aren't happy
with sennak over this potential deal and
seems to want to make some sort of
political Capital out of it to the
detriment of the Prime Minister
okay yes the paper saying a source close
to Johnson said it was his view that it
would be a great mistake to drop the
Northern Ireland protocol bill
this was introduced onto his Premiership
and I think we've all been wondering
when the former prime minister was going
to make his intervention so Rishi sudak
has been negotiating with EU leaders he
flew to Belfast yesterday to speak to
all of the unionist parties there like
the dup to try to get them on the side
there have been positive noises coming
from the EU from the European commission
from and the dup and from other Irish
mutinous parties
um but the former prime minister Boris
Johnson has now
um has now made his intervention he's
warning that it would be a great mistake
to drop the Northern Ireland protocol
bill which is currently making its way
through Parliament but it's sort of
pause it's not progressing and um it's
essentially seen as a as leverage really
it's a way of refuting like saying well
if we don't come to an agreement on this
then we can use this nuclear option of
of overriding parts of the agreement
which was put in place by Boris Johnson
actually when he um agreed the
withdrawal deal with Brussels so it's
all highly contentious we're a really
crucial point and we think a deal is
imminent it's going to be days I think
Richie said that might be speaking to
his back benches tomorrow as soon as
tomorrow trying to get them on side so
it'll be really unhelpful for Richard
boris's coming at this point to stay
what he has to say but at the same time
the issues of Boris Johnson is is
pointing to is that this agreement we
haven't seen the detergent we don't
really know what it is and if it
contains some sort of
um some sort of way of the EU
moderated that ecj is is the key point
of um contention if the deal allows the
EU to do this then there are going to be
some implications for Northern Ireland
which our unionist parties there really
aren't happy with yes it's interesting
Rachel that Kirsten has told the
Observer that he'll be taking the
extraordinary step of offering labor
support in any parliamentary vote on the
agreement
yes that's right so he's basically
um is taking The High Ground in a way he
said you know it should be country first
party second and therefore you know in
the interests of the country
um let's do what it takes to weigh this
bill through and he said to sanak that
he doesn't he doesn't want the prime
minister to worry about quote
um appeasing an intransigent rump of his
own backbenches
um and therefore you know there's
assured him that he doesn't need to
worry about that because he'll he'll
help him get the deal through it's
interesting there's like two tracks of
politics here for sunac there's of
course the internal stuff with his own
party and this is has always been you
know every prime minister
um conservative prime minister since
brexit happened has grappled with you
know the the extreme wing of its party
over brexit so he's got that internal
political calculation but in nationally
that the calculation he seems to be
doing all right I mean the EU is saying
actually it's a bit of a relief to have
someone who's serious a serious
negotiator and not just posturing and
doing things in name only
um he's managed to get you know quite
disparate elements
um in Ireland in the Republic of Ireland
and Northern Ireland
um on board with this and of course
that's really important not just in
terms of getting this brexit uh protocol
sorted in terms of trade and business
but of course would unblock
um storm on the government which is
currently paralyzed because the dup
won't take part of in it over this
precise issue so and the us as well
another Factor the US is sort of quietly
supportive of sunac trying to resolve
this very naughty issue so
internationally it has to be said that
sunak appears to be doing quite well
internally with his own party not so
much
well factoring in the DP as you
mentioned they've urged the Prime
Minister soon act to stand by the
protocol rather than cave in to Brussels
uh which says the bill flouts
international law and just reported here
that Marcus sevkovich the vice president
of the European commission uh is already
boasting about the role of the ecj being
protected and that therein lies that the
bone of contention
Claire
yes I mean it's it it is the main
problem you have EU oversight of a part
of the UK
um it's it's a highly complicated issue
but it was always the real Central
problem of brexit how do you have
Northern Ireland which borders Ireland
which is still part of the EU how do you
trade across across those two
territories without there being a land
border which would infringe The Good
Friday agreement it's the attractable
issue of brexit it's been a problem ever
since this was this you know everyone
started talking about brexit of the
referendum result and it's gonna be
really really hard to resolve there's
some suggestion that Richie sunac has
proposed a sort of mechanism that would
involve Belfast having having to refer
the so the assembly having to refer any
sort of trade dispute to the ecj which
would give them a sort of middleman role
so it wouldn't be ultimately that the
ecj rentage but it's very hard it's one
of the ease red lines that they will not
back down that the ecj have some sort of
rule and they have some sort of power
over this but that is not going to be
acceptable to many people like Boris
Johnson and many of the euras Skeptics
that Richie student act will have to
manage if he wants to get some sort of
deal agreed staying with that Rishi suno
but moving on to the economy the front
page of the telegraph uh reporting that
the prime minister is facing a major
budget Rebellion over his corporation
tax hike Rachel
yeah so this is another thing that's
going on with in his own party and the
internal party Dynamics he wants he's
got a flagship policy actually to raise
corporation tax from 19 to 25 it's worth
remembering that you know 25 was where
it was at before Cameron in 2010
um you know knock slashed it down to
um 19 and 25 would bring it back in line
with you know most European countries
and obviously would bring a lot of money
into the public purse
um at a time when you know we're looking
at pay disputes across the public sector
so it's it's an important one but again
he's got a rump
um sort of
get fundamentalists I guess in his party
who are very sort of slash and burn
um who believe that low tax is the
answer to everything as opposed to uh
something was which is becoming much
more acceptable
um across Europe and certainly in the US
which is look you're gonna have to tax
the rich or the richest
um in order to rebalance an economy that
you know for quite a long time now has
favored the wealthiest at the expense of
the poorest and Claire we read that a
letter to Mr sunak signed by the leaders
of several influential groups of Tory
MPS is urging him to follow a growth
agenda and adopt a Fresh Approach to
encourage investment
uh this is fascinating because it sort
of speaks to how ungovernable sometimes
the Tory party can be and we've seen in
the aftermath of Liz trust obviously she
wanted growth she wanted low taxes she
wanted to attract business to the UK and
we saw how that went her plans back
fired and the market crashed and you've
still got a lot of people in the party
who are like we need to go for growth we
can't you know consign ourselves to sort
of manage decline we need to be
attracting businesses to the UK and by
putting up corporation tax you have the
exact opposite effect by driving
businesses away and we have seen some
really big pharmaceutical companies
saying that because of these plans where
she's Cenac has announced to increase
corporation tax 25 they will be moving
to places that have far lower tax like
Dublin and other places around the world
and they're they're saying that the UK
is not a great place to invest anymore
because it's just too expensive to to
run businesses here so it's a really
careful balancing app that Rishi sudak
will have to have to manage his back
benches who are really pro-growth who
think that list trust may have may have
um she had the right medicine even if
you know it didn't work out and he has
to manage that together with you know
keeping the UK as keeping you know
balancing the books making sure that
enough money is coming into to keep the
economy going Rachel take us to the
Sunday Times and a story that we've been
covering this evening this is the sort
of an Iranian television channel based
in London I believe having to close
their headquarters on the advice of
Scotland Yard because of their threats
to their staff
yeah this is an incredible story so it's
a it's a dissident Iranian TV channel
and it's been forced to stop
um broadcasting from its headquarters in
Britain on advice from Scotland Yard who
have said look we cannot Safeguard staff
um from tehran-backed attacks kidnaps
assassinations
this is incredible advice
um
this is a channel that has been
operating in the UK for some time a lot
of its stuff I don't know how many but
certainly you know a big chunk of them
are British citizens so we've got
um counter-terrorism police Chiefs
saying to British citizens we cannot
protect you on British soil from attacks
from Tehran which seems a staggering
thing to say but that is precisely the
advice
um that staff at this channel have been
given yes about a hundred staff work at
the headquarters are many of them
long-term British residents but as you
say this exceptional advice from
counterterrorism police Chiefs that they
should relocate from London to
Washington DC
Claire just uh very quickly a few few
seconds on this
um it's just very shocking Iran the
director general of MI5 has sort of
labeled around a rogue State they've
said they've had to foil a number of
kidnappings and attempted murders by by
state actors in the UK and we've seen
that you know they're put to death a
British resident recently and who who
used to work for the regime they are
clearly carrying out plots in the UK and
the fact that the police say they can't
manage it is absolutely extraordinary
it's really genuinely worrying yeah it's
very shocking indeed Claire and Rachel
for the moment thank you
coming up we'll take a look at the front
of the Observer which carries this story
food banks at a Breaking Point as demand
hits new highs stay with us for more on
that and Other Stories welcome back you
are watching The Press preview still
with me journalist and author Rachel
shabby and acting Deputy political
editor of the mail on Sunday Claire
Ellicott welcome back to both of you
let's have a look at the Observer to
start with and this story about food
banks more people are depending on them
than ever before in Britain according to
new figures and ever increasing numbers
of households that they're saying
pensioners NHS staff teachers
um quite quite shocking story really
Rachel
it really is an appalling story when you
think about you know the fact that you
know 10 15 years ago Britain didn't
really have a food bank culture it
wasn't a thing
um and now it very much is and food
banks as the Observer is reporting are
at breaking point because of the
increased usage there's been new reports
by the
um independent food Aid Network
um saying that almost
ninety percent of the food banks
surveyed reported in increased demand
between December of last year and
January of this year
um and that if demand Rose further over
half of those are saying they just won't
be able to cope and we'll have to start
turning people away of course it's it's
a chain reaction isn't it because
there's more and more people are
affected by spiraling costs
um and inflation
um people are perhaps less able to
donate to those food banks and then
those food banks are less able to help
more and more people who need that kind
of help in the eye of this crisis so it
is a fairly damning
um statement and we were looking you
know before the break at the idea of
raising corporation tax to 25 this is
why other countries do things like that
it's so that you know we have a contract
with Society we have a safety net Beyond
which people people don't fall and the
way to do that the only way to do that
is to tax the highest earners in society
that's how you manage to get
redistribution and that's how you avoid
this horrible situation where these food
banks are so desperate that they might
now have to start turning people away
Claire and if food banks are at a
breaking point that that suggests that
that much much worse is to come
well yes in some ways but in some ways
not so things are really really bad at
the moment they think um you know
inflation for food is something like
16.7 that's unimaginable a few years ago
um but the key thing is that economists
seem to think that
um inflation has peaked and that things
will start to get better Energy prices
are incredibly bad at the moment but
they're likely to start to come down
soon and hopefully the cost of food
transport and all of those things that
are linked to energy will also start to
come down so there is some hope but it's
undeniable that things are incredibly
hard for everyone at the moment mortgage
prices have gone up food prices have
gone up everybody's finding it really
hard to pay their energy bills and it's
really affecting some of the poorest in
society who've been forced to turn to
food banks it's also affecting middle
class people who aren't usually used to
worrying about these sorts of things so
it's been incredibly difficult time for
Britain and a lot of the western world
and it will no doubt be really tough for
some time yet but the only sort of
Silver Lining is that things should
start to get a bit better sometime soon
Rachel just about 20 seconds on a prince
Andrew worrying that he'll be forced out
of his 30 million pound Windsor home
I mean world's tiniest violin to have
this story following the one on food
banks right
um he fears he'll lose his 30 million
pound home
um the king is looking at slashing his
annual Grant in light of you know all
those accusations of sexual assault uh
which of course prince Andrew continues
to deny
Rachel and Claire thank you so much
we'll see you in the next hour